guys what a season of bachelor in
paradise it was I didn't think people
would stoop that low
her actions trampled people's heart talk
to me about the Kahlan and Blake
conversation tonight because you were
sitting right next to Kaelyn she was in
tears what's the reaction to how Blake
was up there he didn't apologize for
publishing those text messages I think
he truly feels like he did the right
thing and defending himself but also at
the same time I think he should have
seen how her Kaelin was and how much we
all were just like just say sorry and we
couldn't be done with it all it kind of
made me disappointed that he didn't say
sorry but I thought he was a great guy
and like we've really had something we
talked about like skipping paradise and
like coming out with uh you know and
then he like goes to me Blake got a lot
of criticism for releasing those text
messages between him and Kaylin where
did you fall on that I I think it was
really personal moment I don't see a
reason to do that anyway I I mean it'd
be naive to think that that's the only
conversation that was happening to and
if people were telling you not to do it
and then you regret the heat that she
was getting even though you knew it was
gonna happen it just didn't really line
up I feel bad for Kayla Anna did you
think he should have apologized for more
what was your take on it maybe it just
wasn't received as well but he
definitely he put it all out there I
think it's a sticky situation everywhere
I look everyone's talking about how
great Blake is how cute like is how
sweet Blake is and I'm like
if you only know I don't know that I
think that Blake did anything wrong I
think that um I think the whole thing is
just kind of blown out of proportion
I think everyone involved is wrong in a
way I think it's just time to not focus
on who to blame and just focus on
getting past it and coming to a mutual
understanding of how we can treat each
other better let's talk about Blake
because at the finale taping you said do
just say you're sorry
what did Blake honestly do wrong up
there that wasn't a Blake forgiveness
story tonight unfortunately
the things that Blake said I was the
same advice I gave him while he was in
paradise it was like quit with the butt
part of the sentence
say the first part leave it there and
people will respect you they they know
you're not a bad guy you just did some
stupid stuff I think he just kept
digging his hole deeper and deeper and
deeper instead of you know letting it be
where he is stepping out of it moving on
I know what happened with him and
Caitlin
hmm
I honestly thought he would have a
little bit more respect for me so
knowing that he spent the night with her
kind of hurt my feelings how did you
feel about his performance during the
finale I know a lot of people were
saying say sorry but I think for Blake
he had to feel at where I was coming
from to apply to apologize for the text
messages that just doesn't seem right
because I think there's more to it do
you think he should have released them
no there it's a lot of gray area in that
subject just because I again I can only
speak it on my self if I were in his
shoes and somebody told the whole nation
millions of viewers that I silenced
somebody knowing that there's a sexual
assault victim I would find a way to be
like that's not true
but he had a couple of Ally points
sitting in an interview how can he trust
her to say what it is when she lied to
there how do you feel like he handled
tonight though because I have to be
honest watching it I don't think Blake
got a ton of redemption I think he
started off strong and he had the
confidence until other people started by
chiming in and still having an opinion
on it and I think again wants he
crumbled I just think I think like just
needs to let go of his ego recognize
when things are wrong apologize for them
own your actions and on like should be
easier
[Music]